قد تشتد وقد تطول هي ذي مواجهات السودان
المسلحه في قراءه متشائمه اصحابها يجدون
في تكثيف جهود اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه من البلد ما يدعم
رؤيتهم لا يستوقفهم في المشهد حق الدول
تقديم سلامه مواطنيها على اي اعتبار اخر
حيثما تفجرت اضطرابات من اي نوع وانما يشد
انتباههم ما يعتبرون انه اداره المجتمع
الدولي ظهره للسودان في محنته الاحداث
لم يغب ذاك المجتمع عن محاولات السودان ما
بعد الثوره على حكم البشير الخروج من وضع
المازوم اقتصاديا ومحاصر دبلوماسيا وكانت
لافته مرافقته للبلد في محاولته الانتقال
الى الحاله الديمقراطيه التي نشدتها ثورته
للامم المتحده بعثه خاصه لدعم ذلك
الانتقال وتمت الى جانبها اليه ثلاثيه
الحقت بعدها برباعيه
بالرغم من تلاحق المؤشرات لم يحطط احد
بنزع فتيل الازمه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
قبل ان تنزلق الى الاقتتال والان يشكو
كثيرون ما بدا لهم غياب الضغوط المجديه
على طرفي الصراع والعجز عن التاثير
الايجابي على مجريات الاحداث
فحتى الهدن الانسانيه لا ترى كما يبدو من
زاويه كونها فرصه لتوقيع وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار
فالتركيز والزخم الاساسي ظل منصبين بحسب
بعض المتابعين على هدن تتيح اجاء الرعايه
الاجانب وليس على اعمال الاغاثه الانسانيه
او دبلوماسيه السلام
ليست دبلوماسيه حرب خالصه تجادل عواصم
غربيه
لقد اتخذنا قرارا باغلاق السفاره
البريطانيه مؤقتا في الخرطوم واجلاء
الدبلوماسيين البريطانيين وعائلاتهم ونقل
وظائفنا الدبلوماسيه الى موقع دبلوماسي
قريب نواصل العمل بشكل مباشر ومن خلال
شركائنا الدوليين للدعوه الى وقف اطلاق
النار ووضع حد لهذا العنف
هل ثمه اذا قراءه المختلفه لاغلاق
السفارات واجراء الرعايه والدبلوماسيين
الاجانب من السودان ربما فبموازاه تلك
الاجراءات ينشط حديث الوساطات لا سيما
منها الاقليميه من اجل وقف الاقتتال
وانهاء معاناه المدنيين داخل السودان
يتحدث الاتحاد الاوروبي عن اتصالات جاريه
مع كل من البرهان وحميدتي لحذفهما على
انهاء الاقتتال
اما المبعوث النرويجي الخاص للسودان فيؤكد
للجزيره العمل مع قوى اقليميه للتوصل الى
وقف لاطلاق النار
للغايه ذاتها تنسق الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وهما من ابرز القوه الغربيه
المنخرطه في مسيره الانتقال الديمقراطي
المهدده الان في السودان وفي السودان لا
يبدو للناس هناك منصفا المطالبه بممرات
امنه لاجلاء مواطنين اجانب دون الالحاح في
المطالبه بوقف القتال حتى لو الحوا في
الطلب فتمت مشكله
كل اللاعبين الدوليين في السودان لن يبقى
نفسه حتما بعد اكتمال خروج مواطنيهم
ودبلوماسييهم من هناك